هذه الصور للفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس
المجلس السيادي وهو يتابع مجريات هذه
العمليه او هذه العمليات او المعارك
الدائره في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا
صور مشاهدينا تظهر اداره رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهاني
غرفه القياده العسكريه وهذا ما اكده الجيش
السوداني في تصريحات سابقه بان البرهان
فيما كاين امن ويتابع بنفسه هذه العمليات
واذا هذه صور مشاهدينا من داخل الغرفه
غرفه القياده العسكريه وتظهر اداره رئيس
وتظهر اداره رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح ابو برهان لهذه الغرفه
ولعمليات العسكريه الجاريه الان في
الخرطوم ومناطق سودانيه مختلفه بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات